Thanks so let me just recap what we left
off last time okay the thing coming from
last time was that the perfect matching
on planar graphs can be computed if you
have a Fafi on orientation and that's
the case if it's a planar graph and then
we have defined what's called a match
gates which is basically a planar graph
with some external nodes and we for each
match gate we define a signature it's
called tensor or a vector of values
basically you take a nap a turn of zero
ones of external nodes and you remove
them and you look at the graph left and
we'll see some examples in a bit and
then you think about its perfect
matching value and that's the value
assigned at that entry so that's the
entry defined by the perfect matching
with the pattern of the vertices removed
summing over all perfect matchings of
the graph remaining of the weight of the
particular if all the ways I wanted just
accounting the number particular and
then we also mentioned the last time
that the perfect matching can be
counting perfect matching can be
expressed at in such uniform wake or the
Holland problem where you assign the
exact one function at every vertex and
look at edges as variables and then you
take the edge to be in or out and for
every particular pattern locally for
every vertex exactly one is incident is
the perfect matching requirement and the
sum over zero ones where the zeros
indicate it's not a valid matching one
indicate it is becomes the number of
perfect matchings right so this is just
a way formalizing it's like expressing
your satisfiability problem in
constraint satisfaction problem or
something you know you just write down a
particular set of functions that will
talk about this problem
and then of course then this really is
an example of this this expression this
framework of addressing counting
problems where you think about the graph
you think about a set of constraint
functions sitting on the vertices and
then the edges are variables let's just
think about 0 1 assignments of the
variables and then you evaluate at every
vertex so here for example is a non zero
one example where if you say I want to
talk about edge coloring okay so you
pick red or blue or green three
different possibilities for the edge and
then edit every vertex is the constraint
that aren't we talked about that the
knot or equal constraint okay so the
vertex says all the edges must be
different and that's a 0 1 valued
constraint function and the product of
that is the conjunction in this case
everywhere at every vertex looks like
the edge constraint satisfaction is
satisfied that they're all different
color and you sum over all this and it
becomes a number of valid edge colorings
right so so you can pick anything so
that we you like then and pretty soon
we'll see that for the idea of the
holographic reduction it really behooves
us to not to restrict these values to be
just zero one's good it's the the true
understanding comes around by looking at
them as numbers in fact we'll come to
the point where I want to argue that
even like unlike constraint satisfaction
problem where you have so the duo view
of variables and the constraints try to
think about variables are another kinds
of constraints which is just saying they
are all equal at this good
this constraint ok that's the variable
that variable has to be consistent in
assigning values that's all ok and we're
going to change these functions around
and you're going to see that the
Equality constraint is is a perfect a
bona fide constraint functions just like
easing constraint or something ok all
right so let's look at an example of
something that is naturally expressible
as a Holland problem and then solve the
in polynomial time by this this method
of match gates and cast aliens algorithm
even though on the surface if it may
look like they would require exponential
time so the instance is your planar
graph of maximum degree three and in
fact for this talk let's just think of
them as a regular Surrey graph so every
vertex has degree 3 and you're looking
for orientations so orientation is the
assignment of a direction for each edge
either this way or that way and then
every vertex this is called the Ising
model awesome ice Model something you
want at every vertex so that it is not
the case that everybody coming in or
everybody going away so two coming in
one coming out is ok one coming in to
come out is ok but it is not ok to
everybody coming in so I suppose this
these models come from Pauling's in
these chemistry or physics where you
have these local ice models and you have
some local constraints and you look at
the configurations as a valid and then
you you think about them as some sort of
weight or energy I'm not going to get
into that I'm really no expert in that
but let's just say i'm talking about a
graph problem ok so you have every local
constraint to be a nun or equal so this
is really a no sink no sauce if you are
graph there is this is just no sink and
those source orientation ok there's
another way purely another way of saying
it but now think in terms of the Holland
problem what you have now is that at
every vertex
okay let's say you have a degree 3
vertex then the constraint is the knot
or equal okay you think about so the
coming in or going away at 0 or 1 and
then you're saying it's not all 0 or not
whole 101 I mean we complete the
scientists think about 01 this is
another way of saying yes or no you know
out up and down it is just a spinning
whatever all right now what about okay
so this is a notation it says that if I
have a function that is a symmetric in
the sense that the value only depends on
the number of ones ok so you another way
of saying it is invariant on the
permutation of the variables that's a
symmetric function then I can specify
such a function with only the value on
the Hamming weight of 0 1 2 up to n so n
plus 1 values will specify the function
except unlike if it's a general case
will be 2 to the n values will specify
the truth table so in the case of the
nut or equal then you're saying if the
Hamming weight is 0 and hamming weight
is 3 they are both no good that's a zero
output and if the Hamming weight is one
wanting to out or towing one out then
it's fine so this is just a shorthand to
say here is the function but you can
also think of this as a shorthand of
writing down in this case two to the
three numbers three inputs truth table
okay and it will be indexed as 0 0 0 for
the 0 value 0 0 1 for the one value 0 1
0 0 1 1 1 0 and da da da da da ok so you
can write down my dimension eight vector
and the way I'm liquid laboring on this
sort of thing is because we are about to
do arithmetic operations linear
algebraic operations on these so far
merely an assemblage of values and we're
going to think about them as truly good
honest factors in some vector space and
we're going to transform them in in this
tensor way okay so this is why it's also
important now that we should not think
about them as a
ian merely pulling their values of
indicating true or false but it's just
numbers now okay now what about the
orientation well there's a standard way
to reduce CSP to Holland problems so in
some sense column is a bit more
expressive but here's an example
basically it took took every take every
edge you you do what's called stretching
you replace it by a path of length 2
okay and then on that vertex the new
vertex on the lens the past 2 then you
you can have a constraint on them so
you're basically saying originally this
was a variable and here are the
constraints sitting on them okay but now
i'm going to replace this by saying here
is a new variable and that the f is
still sitting on them g is sitting on
them but i have an equality function so
this function now takes variables here
and there and ostensibly this originally
was 0 1 and ostensibly there were four
possibilities but it's in fact only two
possibility will be valid because the
Equality forces the both sides to be
okay so this is just a slight of hand is
trivial this gadget of yours right write
down a path of length ok another way if
you think in graph theoretic Lee this is
the edge vertex incidence graph ok so it
becomes a bipartite graph on the one
side is all degree to these are the
original edges and they're all equality
of binary to and the other side of the
original constraints and in this
bipartite view you think of this as a
constraint satisfaction for only like
the equality's are going to be treated
soon enough as as perfectly good
constraint functions we're going to
transform them like ordinary vectors now
in this particular example it's not the
Equality I want orientation so on this
particular example what i have is
actually the assignment of so that this
way or that way and will be naturally
represented by the following possibility
of
0 1 0 1 0 and then i will then just do
the following trick right second the
trillest gadget with a disequilibrium
for possibilities but it's just you know
0 1 1 0 its orientation good so on the
one side there will be vertices labeled
by binary dis equality functions on the
other side will be the original
constraint functions not or equal
function but this equality on binary is
also not equal not all equal if you will
ok so there they are all dis equality's
in some sense right now this is the the
holland view of what what this no sink
and no sauce orientation problem is okay
alright so as i said this is the edge
vertex incidence graph and then the hole
and some can be now viewed as summing
over all possible zero ones on half
edges so there are this 2 to the 2 e
terms and for each one of those terms of
a 0 ones you're subject to the
constraint that they are all satisfied
those aged dis equality or sensor and
those are all satisfied and to satisfy
two things of a constraint function as a
truth table you can ride them as a
tensor product of the two vectors think
about tense as a vector because it's a
say say think of a 0 ones when you say
you know a 0 0 a 0 1 a 1 0 a 1 1 is a
binary function and here is another
binary function p 0 0 V 0 1 B 10 b 11
and you multiply them out or out it's
one if and only if both are one that's
the tensor product in the most primitive
and none of this high bro tensor algebra
you think of the kronecker product right
just multiply this with this multiply
this with this okay you expand out you
have a four dimensional vector tensor
four dimensional vector you get a 16
dimensional vector and that 16
dimensional vector every entry is just a
one entry here x 1 entry there and it's
one if and only if both are one if the 0
1 k
the weight then it just multiplies it's
exactly what we want ok so the tensor
product here represents exactly the sort
of in the boolean case the conjunction
in the CSP language is exactly what the
gadget should be ok so now if you write
down all the constraints on the edges on
one side as a tensor products and that
will give you a vector of 2 to the 2 e
dimension and on the right side you also
tensor product all those constraints and
that's also giving you 2 to the 2 e
Direction division and then you do a dot
product term by term it is just summing
over all possible 01 possibilities of
these half edges of potential
orientation assignments and subject to
the constraint that if it is a valid
constraint of orientation ok first on
the left side says is it the case that
you're assigning two different values
for each edge so it's an orientation on
the right side it says yeah my thing
coming some are 0 some are one not all 0
ok and another constraint said nope yeah
imma for I'm fine I'm fine and if any
one of those is violated then the whole
product becomes zero so that becomes a
zero terming that this dot product so
this whole long dot product is merely a
statement of the original problem trying
out all possibilities so if I'm done
nothing ok this is absolutely nothing
totally Trivium just re saying one is a
one is a one is one that's all ok maybe
one plus one is two all right good all
right so so we are going to assign these
functions and think about them is a
shorthand of dimension 8 vector here and
there will be tensor product
and now I'm going to ask you to do think
of this dot product is a long vector and
the computation is is is is is
unthinkable right this is like you know
2 to the 2 e term computation and it's
no better than just enumerated our
possibilities however I'm going to ask
you now to think about what's called a
holographic transformation okay I'm
going to ask you to change your vector
by this okay so in particular I told you
this was really an a dimensional vector
and this ain't dimensional vector i can
multiply the h by a tensor power 3 okay
and effectively graphically what we are
doing is to change the function on this
f by the new function which is you do an
H here H here and H here and if you did
this transformation you get a new a
dimensional vector and in fact i
computed this for you and here now
algebra comes in nicely you don't want
to really write down a dimensional
vector and matrix and multiply you can
do this this thing which i guess in a
more abstract definition of tensor
product and tensors this is the
definition of thing that the you are
multi linear you can distribute of
products ok so the tensor of a matrix
multiplied by a tensor of vectors is the
tensor of the product so a times B 10 so
something is a tensor times be tensile
that distributes it that's you know in
the more more more advanced treatment of
tensor practices with the definition of
thing okay but but you can directly
verify this is the case alright but now
i am writing this same remembered what
is this is a dimensional vector which
has a 0 in the 000 place and 0 at the 11
one place and one in the six other
places right that's the vector that's a
dimensional vector merely sulfa is just
a truth table of saying true force but
I'm thinking of those numbers now and
I'm expressing it in the following way
see this guy gives me an a dimensional
vector of all ones and this guy chris
muir a a dimensional vector of a single
one at the zero
00 place and this gives me a a
dimensional vector at the one on one
place so I'm taking all ones subtracting
two ones at the beginning at the end I
get exactly the vector I want this is a
reassembling of what originally was a
boolean value the 01 but now I'm writing
it as if they are perfectly good honest
numbers and doing arithmetic on them and
the tensor product does the distribution
so what is H times the 111 well that's
that's like you add the two columns
together so it gives 20 right 20 tends
to eight of three gives you an eight
dimensional vector of 80 000 000 ok and
then you hocus pocus you get this number
ok so this is obvious I mean now you can
see so that some strange things
happening I'm as we are breaking apart
and originally a perfect good logical
design from Intel it says true false
da-da-da-da-da and now I'm assembling it
into so the superposition if you like
quantum superpositions of these other
funny pieces which don't really exist in
reality and then my computation somehow
distributes and gives me the computation
I want and similarly I can do the other
way and this I'm doing the inverse
transformation actually should be the
English and n transpose but this is a
symmetric saz fine and in fact it's
almost its own inverse up to effective
to write quantum people would insist
writing this as a 1 over square root of
two so that is so no but to us constant
factors don't matter so all right so you
get this okay so you get this number now
what's the big deal I mean why isn't
0110 more beautiful than 60 minus 20
with what have you done what you have
done is the following that turns out
that these guys are matched case
signatures okay and if you can transform
to something by this holographic
transformation that the Holland value
the dot product is unchanged because
what you really have done is you have a
dot product and you're multiplying some
big matrices so you have this dot
product and here and i'm multiplying by
an H and H inverse
to its high power and then distributes
the tensor product all over so the value
is unchanged but then i can imagine that
as if the local function is not the f
but this 60 minus 20 and now you can see
that that the minus do come in and that
this is important that I allow myself
this freedom to do this business yeah
all right and these two turns out that
our match gates so here is a proof by by
example or the demonstration by
construction right so I'm claiming this
is a match gay and if you take away any
pattern of these three vertices 6 plus 8
possibilities really but by symmetry
really only for possibility by parity is
only two possible okay so he counted the
even you know you can't take all three
out because it's even or left thread so
you can take a 1 or 3 out okay if you
take all sweet out sorry take a one-take
take how many I can't count it's six of
them so I have to take a zero or take
two out thank you very much even odd
gets me okay so so you take two out
let's say you take one and A two out
it's a symmetric so you take the one or
two L then this map must be matched here
and this must be matched there okay and
this is just giving you a scalar six so
there's a minus two
and if you take none out then this must
match this must match this must match
you get 6 ok so this is just an example
of a match key ok it's the perfect
matching after you remove some external
nodes and you look at the perfect
matching then you somehow in general of
course there will be exponentially many
possible things inside you have the sum
and you've added and subtracted and so
forth but here's a particularly simple
example just to show that this is a
match case signature or so now imagine
that I'm plugging in this thing by that
ok and then the 01 business and I'm
going to plugging something here too as
a match gates and then I'm thinking 01
as taking the perfect matching in taking
this edge in the perfect matching or not
and then summing over all possible such
patterns and a given the external
pattern of taking or not taking and then
think about all possible internal
perfect matchings it takes a moment to
think but but I think you can convince
yourself after few seconds that this
final thing really is the counting of
the total perfect matchings of the
entire graph once i have replaced these
guys by the match gates so this is sort
of in a nutshell with holographic
algorithm to reduction to match gates is
all about i have the original constraint
somehow sitting somewhere and that
expresses the problem i want to solve it
is a hollin problem let's say and then i
will try to replace it after a
holographic transformation by some other
constraint functions so that they are
actually now match gate signatures and
if they are match case signatures i can
use custodians algorithm to find so it
is still at this point there's a long
exponential dot product but that's not
how i'm going to compute this write this
quantity representing another
realization as the perfect matching of
the girl
so I'm going to do it the castalian way
okay so that that's the sort of in a
nutshell what this and here's another
match case that does this okay so then
it becomes sort of a I should say that
less Valley introduced this and there
were some magical problems that he said
he could solve like you know counting 3
mod so some some very strange problem
that the you really wouldn't think about
so monotone read twice counting of
number of satisfactions mod seven so you
want the answer to be the number of
satisfactions to be either zero or one
or two or three or four five six and and
there's a companion problem says if it's
just more to let says even odd and it
turns out that the mall to is already
hard okay NPR and it turns out more
seven in this case it's solvable in
polynomial so they are these sort of a
pretty strange solved in palm and then
that behooves us you know in the
classification perspective what are
solvable I mean okay so you can be very
ambitious and say I want I want to solve
and sharpey hard problem that's what I
want in polynomial time so what I
instead say is that let's try to capture
as trying to really carve out exactly
what these things can do and so one step
forward is to say for example
characterize all the signatures that
were realizable by match gates that are
symmetric and I will seeing a bit too
that we have characterizations for all
signatures that are represented by match
gates and they turned out to be related
to something called a spinner variety
and they are captured by this class of
equations called match gates identities
welcome today
okay so shifting gear I want to talk
about the sort of another class of
holographic algorithms that have nothing
to do with reduction to the castalian
stuff okay in particular they will work
not just for planar graphs but for any
grass so recall that I'm writing a
symmetric signature in this way the
hanging weight of any way 0 value
Hamming weight 1 value and so on and
look at this guy okay so it's a
perfectly good 01 you can't complain
about 01 even though I argue that you
shouldn't even complain about non 0 1
but being such 01 you really can't
complain right it says you know I just
don't like you to have exactly 10 k 0 is
ok to is ok three is ok but right now
this by some perspective is it's a
Fibonacci sequence right this is equal
to these two summit is equal these two
some so now it turns out that we can
define such a signature as a Fibonacci
gate if it satisfy the Fibonacci
recurrence ok so i can write down
fibonacci sequence in any long line and
then these will be functions you can put
on a graph and then you can say well
what is the holland problem what's the
value on that ok it turns out that these
are computable in polynomial so i think
it it was a bit of a surprise that leads
to us
but more importantly actually this
actually represents a class of problems
that are tractable and not only that on
top of that it represents a basic
ingredient in the classification so this
represents one big class of the
tractable class of the classification
dichotomy theorem where you say it's
either this or this of it and this is
one of things that are transformable to
this biology so this took us actually
several years to evolve into this
perspective where we're going to get to
a point where even the expression so so
we start off with holographic
transformation there's a tool to do some
algorithms and very fantastic algorithms
and then we come to a point where we use
the holographic reductions as a tool to
prove hardness as a reduction method and
hardness but then it comes the point
where we actually going to express the
statement of what is tractable what is
not in terms of holographic
okay um so so this is the statement that
this thing is if you put Fibonacci there
in any graph doesn't have to be planar
now this is and I don't want to get into
the details but and it details not that
difficult but basically the proof that
is tractable one way of proving it is to
say that if I have to Fibonacci
signatures I merge two edges of the
external edge and I get a new perfect
new signature of you know if there was
four and three I get a five okay arity
five variables and I prove that this is
also a Fibonacci so it's not I think
obvious from from the face of it but but
it is ok can just check it is so and
once you have that oh there is another
operation that you do the self loop of
2x and then you can say that you can
just sort of engine imagine that you
have a signature grid with Fibonacci's
everywhere and you email initially you
cut off every connections and they're
all Fibonacci's individually and you
merge one piece after another after
another you kept saying it's Fibonacci
it's Fibonacci's in the end it's just a
fable notch and it's a number ok so this
is like is brain-dead algorithm
and the same argument actually works for
the so called generalized Fibonacci that
if you have a parameter arbitrary
parameter City same argument works and
oh here the definition was called a
generalized equality which is you put
any number here whence 0 0 NE number
else doesn't have to be same doesn t 0
it could be 0 even any number one and if
there anything this equal then the
output 0 it requires them to be equal or
the input but output may be something
else and it turns out that if you take
this class these are the things that
satisfy the Fibonacci recurrence with
one exception with one or two exception
and and you add this guy in which is not
expressible this way then then they they
are they are so the verb i buy a if you
take the view of group actions then you
can argue that they are the same orbit
and then also but basically they are all
the same in this holographic
transformation ok so here's a theorem
says that anything in this is equivalent
to the following that they exist nor go
no that goes to here oh there's
orthogonal to the original Fibonacci or
is an orthogonal to anything in there on
the orthogonal is a single orbit and
this interestingly is not even though my
tractability argument works for all ok
put this in a deeper understanding of
this class of signatures this is
actually different this is what's called
vanishing that's it
okay so there are some characterizations
of Fibonacci Bates and what can be
transformed but what is in fact
interesting to us was that it turns out
that the Fibonacci's characterize what
is this class called Holland star where
I think we actually had this name before
the conservative wing of the the
community came we were we were liberal
we didn't call it a concern but anyway
so we call it the Holland star okay just
says that you know you're throwing all
the unary see you like turns out that
these you Nerys what universe are
Fibonacci okay okay
let me let me bring some other sort of
basic ideas a signature is called a
degenerate if it is a tensor product of
unary ones and in fact this is sort of
the reason one of the reason why you
Nerys are being singled out in a very
very special way because they are very
weak okay if a signature is degenerate
then basically what the signature is
saying is that my value doesn't really
depend on of three or it depends
obviously but my value with respect to
your contribution is already determined
by what your value is and I can split
this into sort of three unary functions
each one of them only looking at the
input respectively is a degenerate
that's why okay DJ and if it's a binary
function that's degenerate then it's
exactly the same as the two-by-two
matrix or K by K matrix if it domain hey
then the rank is once you can decompose
into a outer product of one vector with
another and so therefore is to the
splinters at this point okay so if
you're having to generalize is tractable
and then now we define what's called a
product type and all of this definition
that will lead to the claim that you
have a class of this problems CSP column
and you want to say what are tractable
and here are the classes product type
and we'll see the affine type vanishing
type and salsa so here is the product
type very simple a function is
expressible as equality's and generalize
equality's and disequilibrium
these are called a quiet time okay so it
turns out that Fibonacci basically
captures the product type okay so in the
conservative star liberal world hollins
star of a set of constraint function is
either polynomial time computable or
sharpy heart and it is paulina my time
if a known if it is of this following
type okay arrogant most to which then
you can do what's called a trace by
matrix product or it is under a suitable
transformation it becomes the product
type so this is not the original way we
found or proved these theorems but this
is like the transformational perspective
of what conceptually what it is okay or
there's a one extra thing which is this
so the 2i type Fibonacci which is
actually vanished okay so this is the
first classification oh let me mention
that someone mentioned self several you
told me that you didn't get chance to
copy down to my book address it's a diet
dichotomy dash book PDF on my website
and this is chapter one so this is like
where I start the theory using this and
it turns out that the ability to
construct unary ones is very important
in the later work and that's why this is
okay let me move on to CSP everybody
already knows the definition you have a
set of constraint functions and now you
really think sort of a you know you know
I called separate way you have variables
here and constraints there and constrain
apply to the variables and then you sum
over the variables and multiply over the
constraints now I want to introduce
another class called f-fine and here are
here's the definition you have some
constant you have a support a
characteristic 0 1 function on an F Phi
linear subspace and then you have I the
square root of our 1-1 to a exponent of
zero one indication functions summed up
and each one of them is the 01
indication functions of an fi linear
subspace okay so this is what what this
there's an alternative way of writing
this and I think that's sort of a nice
indication that some classes nice if you
have actually more than one way of
looking at it here's another way of
looking at it turns out that the thing
up there can be viewed as a quadratic
polynomial in the excise with this one
additional constraint that the cross
terms must have even turned even
coefficient then these iphone only who
you can't give away this is not this
isn't one of the nice thing about the
economy theorem is that the once you
prove that you can say it's not that we
didn't do it right the theorem says this
is the right definition
now to get some concrete understanding
of this class let's think about the
symmetric functions of this class and
they turn out to be expressible in these
three families and I'm now already
taking the liberty of writing them as
tensor product sums so you should think
about this as a vector of 2 to the K
long as a truth table of a function but
I'm expressing it as sums of tensors and
sort of there they came ready to be
transformed by holographic
transformations okay now I hope nobody
will complain that I have complex
numbers around and you will see that in
fact that they are really essential okay
in for example I think David though was
talked about was was she talked about
that this for the graph homomorphism
case ok if it's 00 01 10 they are all
one and one one is negative one that
counts the number of all the induced
subgraphs perfectly 01 question is
expressible in this family by choosing
one plus i as the lambda and in the
third family
now if you think a little deeper in fact
you should not really be surprised why
sees these sort of a perfectly good
honest 201 kind of things will give rise
to complex numbers because these are the
eigenvalues it is really the eigenvalues
in the analysis of these problems that
give a rise yes horribly to these
complex numbers must make their
appearance so I'm going to make no
apologies henceforth that things could
possibly be complex
so if you expand them out as you see for
example this is a binary function if you
truncate off of one one one minus one is
this other map function whose graph
homomorphism status was open for quite
some time and this family are all
trapped this is all in the f1 fan and
then comes the next theorem for the
dichotomy for the CSP and this extends
the holland star it says and the proof
of this uses the holland star to say
that we have two classes basically have
tractable here it's either in F fine or
in product let me caution this statement
is to say that's either entirely fi or
entirely in P is not that it's contained
in F I Union p the economics and this is
in fact one of the substantial amount of
proofs when in later here too but in
later dichotomies where you want to
argue that are no mixing unlike the
Markov chains you like mixing hear you
say they are no mixing so speak chapter
big sections of long papers with devoted
to proving no mixing oh I should mention
that that there's quite a bit of a
pre-work that you know builds up into
this and many of the people in English
audience had contributed to this side
you're very Brazilian would be is
product type these are the holographic
transformations of Fibonacci with one
additional data sheet
so I mentioned some of these so far been
really focused on just boolean domain
but let me mention that she already
talked about the graph homomorphism in
the general domain higher domain that's
substantially more work and the
constraint satisfaction for general
domain Andre also mentioned so the graph
homomorphism partition function comes
from here and if you're interested here
you should be able to copy this fast
because I'm not going to able to have
time to write down here but it's
collected here quite a good collection
number of papers that he or his course
was not written 30 40 papers over
okay so this is the dichotomy theorem
starting with dire and green hills for
the 01 case and she talked about this
really beautiful extension by bullet off
and grow on the on the non- case it's
particularly nice because it's very much
usable okay you can use that as a
criteria to prove other things and then
there were the paper by let me get this
right I think Goldberg cool j three on
the real the real is a is a real
progress because there are the
cancellations and the cancellation is
the source of tractable problems and
because the presence of these beautiful
tractable things to prove that nothing
else becomes a much harder
okay um so this is the thing maybe she
will talk about that will skip this
again there's a long list of a beautiful
work before that so let me mention a
dichotomy we know about Holland problems
which is a bit harder because it really
the economy of this would imply the CSP
and furthermore I try to classify for
planar problems like going back to the
cast aliens type and as I have to
mention last time already the upshot
that we seem to come to understand and
not fully proved is that for Holland
problems it turns out that this
holographic reduction to the latch gates
is not universal but for CSP type for
the planar it is and it's ironic because
the castalian was really designed for
this the matching problem it's the
Holland type it's not a serious so I
think it still requires some
understanding
so here's a notion of called a C Class C
transformable that there is some
transformation that makes the equality
is on the edge to the sea and the
constraints into the sea as well so this
is like just what you think should be
the contravariant transformation the
covariant transformation now I'm
speaking in tongues intensive so here's
the theorem that says you're given a
symmetric complex-valued functions on
boolean variables arbitrary disregarding
planarity this problem is either shall
be hard if or its satisfy the following
English case would be in polynomial time
and here are the few classes there's the
F fiying type the f I'm transformable
the product type P transformable the so
the degenerate era d at most two type
that's the trace computation I think
yesterday was a talking physics where
you assume some random model where you
say that it's likely that the local
thing is a tree and then things are easy
to compute that's basically with this a
cyclic you can just compute in this way
and and then there are two classes that
involve vanishing okay and i think i
will actually skip this part because it
will take a little doing to really
define what these things are quickly a
signature is vanishing if you put it in
a signature grid and if the signature
grid only concern only use these
vanishing ones at the same type this
type is either plus or minus type then
the value will be 0 and this phenomena
seemed to only occur if you have complex
numbers like 1 I your dot itself becomes
0 okay now you say well okay so who
cares about these things what turns out
that they actually interact with other
things so that when you are not just
vanishing but there are other things it
would produce non-vanishing values but
the classification would require the
understanding of the vanish so if you
are entirely vanishing without any part
here yes your attractable and a value is
a simple zero but that's that's an you
know how can you say you don't care
about that but you must because
together with others will produce
nonzero ones and in order to understand
what is tractable you must understand
all that this is again my philosophical
reversion to the claim that these things
self justify their own existence by this
theorem let me mention this match case
identity so remember you are given a
match gate and you assign a match gates
signature okay and then the claim is
that it satisfies the match case
identity and in fact there's a separate
part of the proof that says that if you
do satisfy all these then you are the
match gates so this is a complete
characterization of it and the match
case identity says that if you take any
two patterns of zero one that's the
number of external nodes you do the XOR
which have a bunch of zeros that's the
place with alpha beta are different and
then you some this funny-looking thing
or the sum of alternating sum of these
values where you flip the bits where
they differ okay so you have alpha
pattern beta pattern and you started to
flip bosing are running beta of the
places where they differ and you
multiply the menu alternate summer you
get this and you get zero this is the
claim it must be so and the original
thing was for narrative for ending a
very concrete case you have for external
things and you you you prove that 16
values of this thing satisfy this that's
and we have arrived at the proof and
eventually God we thought to be a better
prove because they were really
complicated force but I would really
like to show you a new proof by Mark
jerem who was reading this and said oh I
have a better proof of course he does
so I'll show you the favor pool so what
are we supposed to prove we have two
patterns and they are differ on these
guys now let's take two perfect
matchings because it's the perfect
matching summing over all these guys
it's going to be the signature entry for
which you are multiplying together and
then you assemblage again and right
inside here are the sums the way this
sounds are the perfect matchings of
these guys so let's take one here take
one there ok what did I tell you the
last time that if you have two perfect
matchings what do you do the first thing
you do that's a little Chris here for
the students of course you superimpose
yeah that's the only thing you do so
once you superimpose you get a bunch of
these are perfect matchings all the
graph where you already removed some
external nodes so they're not in the
same graph so in this case you have
cycles even lens and the pass but both
cycles and paths are alternating so one
edge is in m1 edges in M Prime and so on
so forth but the e sub P sub I so this
is the 0 0 0 0 1 at the piece of eye
place and 1 1111 sex or says I'm
flipping the p.i bit of offer that's
where often beta are different so that
external nodes rpi one of them is it in
the removal pattern one of them is out I
don't know which one but it's definitely
one is anyone out okay so therefore that
must lead a pass not a cycle a pass that
starts with an edge that's are they in
em or M Prime it's only only exactly one
of them then followed by the other kind
and then alternate and will end up
somewhere it cannot end up with a cycle
so it has to end up somewhere and that's
the p sub j where they differ where they
often baited differ so this if you take
two perfect matchings it will define
this alternating path to a p sub j
somewhere okay and now if you think
about this as a planar saying
then this piece of I leads to a piece of
Jay the external differences of piece of
case must in even number because they
are also leading paths of alternating
paths that cannot cross this so it has
to go over the over there so therefore
the Jay and I must be of a opposite
parody ok so this sets up I want to
incur is at so from some I any I will
give you an a JM j and this is an
involution if you start with the flipped
matching pair you come back you get to
the exactly original pair so this sets
up with a one-to-one correspondence with
a total and you can check the weights
match and so on and this will set up
this is exactly the negative sign the
sum term there's the positives some term
okay
ok so that even of just alternate
let me mention that a beautiful theorem
due to Hong and Tyson that says that if
I now talk about CSP with planner
restriction and the functions are
complex valued and symmetric then it is
now either in F fine or in product or in
this transform the match gates so this
is the sort of the statement giving
weight to the claim that this is a
universal for the things that are
tractable in polynomial time of a
planner but generally not because this
this captures things that were not
these sorry this captures things that
are tractable in the non-planar case let
me skip the edge
I mean shifting gear 45 some minutes to
talk about a technique that it's very
often used in these reductions we start
with the top polynomial if you have
never seen at a polynomial I think it's
impossible to grasp this at this point
but it's some polynomial in two
variables X Y and JJ verdict in Welsh
has a theorem says that other than these
values or this parabola it is sharpy
heart otherwise it's Parliament and over
the planer ones you have one additional
parabola that is polynomial
here's the definition of what's called
the medial graph so you've given such a
graph of planar graph you take every
edge to be a new vertex and if they
share the same face you put an edge in
it okay and this now you take the black
parts out this is called the media graph
and one more definition an Oriole Aryan
orientation so you come to a vertex oil
Aryans so the path you come in come out
come in come out you always can just
come around right so it's not a surprise
to say that I wanted the number of
things in to be equal to number of
things out that's obviously necessary
condition but it's also sufficient okay
so here's a serum due to a las vegas
this says that that the top polynomial
evaluated these that this particular
pair of points 3 comma 3 is the sum over
the media graph of saddle points where
set of points are things the orientation
is in out in out summing over
orientations and at saddle points you
put this factor too okay so and since
this is hard this is hard and this is
really a column problem in it's
perfectly good honest way you have
orientations / edges we already did this
and then what's the constraint at the
vertex oh I should say that the medial
graphs are always for regular okay the
planar graph okay so you're talking
about vertices that are degree 4 and you
want in out eating out
ok and a signature for that is obviously
a aiready full function that says 00 01
10 okay whatever the value is okay and
that turns out to be for this particular
thing in order to capture the saddle is
this thing okay 00 01 10 11 coming from
one direction 1 00 01 10 11 coming from
the other direction I'm drawing it this
way you can imagine that this sort of
four wires coming in in the orientation
and it gives you the value all the non
zero values happen on the weight to part
now it turns out that i can do this
transformation the sulphides of course
it is 0-1 values and the perfect if I
you're saying wait I like to do a
complex transformation okay so here's
the I sitting in there and turns out
that the the Z transformation will
transform this this equality into
equality and under the Z transformation
this signature I just told you becomes
this so this is my if you like quantum
you can think of this as the
superposition of the external 0011 world
with inside of the 01 10 world but
whatever it's a 16 numbers it's just a
book the truth table of this function
okay and this is the function after the
transformation under z okay now what
about the Doyle Aryan orientation well
this is says that it's a 2 into out
everything else is 0 under the Z
transformation if becomes 30 103 again
magic of holographic transformation sure
computation right so what we like is to
reduce you know the cut to the oil area
and if i do this gadget this is a
slightly more advanced gadget than the
single edge gadget you put oil airing
everywhere that gives you a new Harrity
full function ok and you can compute
this this is this
once you have this then you would like
to transfer you can reduce the top to
this that's what you like and that will
prove the hardness of the oil airing
orientation you go from the top to this
on the holographic transformation go to
that
or an area orientation so you have these
two matrices you like to try to
interpolate this by that and what you do
is you design now a sequence of gadgets
you replace the one you have by sort of
a sequence of things that you would like
to reduce from and once you do that you
might sort of impressionistic we believe
me if you don't quite work out a detail
that if this guy's 00 01 10 11 coming
out and here's 00 01 10 11 coming out
and this is 0 0 0 1 1 it's like a matrix
product in order to somehow get the
signature of this okay yeah you're
writing / sum over all possible 00 01 10
11 and that's the matrix of 4 x 4 x 4
Zweifel and so if you think that way
then the iteration gives you iterative
multiplication and if it iterative
multiplication and eigenvalues is
natural right and this is why complex
numbers sort of the you know this is
very natural okay but in this case
actually we can do in a direct
arithmetic and use some the valley you
want stratified according to how many
times this occurs how many times these
two types occur and how many times this
ochre and once you have that you can
express your value in this way where c
IJ is the sum over all other things all
over the place with this three to the J
many times and the other term the once
you replace the s times you get this and
by prime factorization these guys are
going to be different from this
and so you would get is a linear system
with these as coefficients and this
coefficient matrices this coefficient
matrix is a van de menthe that there's
known degenerate and you can just argue
every different i j k and j prime K
prime topple they would be not the same
and so therefore you can solve for these
once you solve for the CIJ you can go
back to Seoul for this that's the
reduction okay and I think I'll stop
here thank you very much
question
so you think this project is ever going
to end well there's a lot of things that
still unknown maybe I should mention a
few things that are unknown right so for
example for the Holland dichotomy we
have basically only done the symmetric
functions furthermore it is basically
almost entirely on the boolean domain so
if you have higher domain we have
virtually very we have only one result
there's the planner thing which again
for the Holland we have no idea for
symmetric we have but a symmetric
functions later
so I mean you mentioned the result on
planar special Roman plane is running by
special well I mean it's basically Zulu
you yes yes only on Borneo yeah so
beyond bored ian and planners it's
virtually no
so
a future find hope and near the terms
that are very crucial I don't know I I
would you know encourage students or
anyone who is interested you know look
into the things and see there are lots
of things that are unknown for example
we are currently trying to get it's
what's called a six vertex model
statistical physics people like you have
a matrix like this
and the support is on weight 2 so 2 into
out and I guess the physics motivation
was that you have grids and you have
functions sitting on them and you have
orientations and every time you some
physics reason that it has to be tweaked
to out and then you have a value and you
multiply them so
that would of course fall into the
holland dichotomy if we have a Holland
fool Holland but this is not symmetric
now so but even for that it seems quite
challenging and there are new tractable
problems in this in a planner case that
are not by holographic transformation to
the match gains which is a new thing we
really don't have a lot of understanding
so why are they buy if they're not my
match so so it's a it's a global
realization that you view it in a
different way and then you identify
psychos as new variables and then you do
holographic transformation on that graph
so it's a but you have to argue very
carefully that you didn't break plan
ality and then neither is this sort of
psycho thing they can do
any other questions ok well let's break
for lunch